pan du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est un monsieur
philippe cochet merci monsieur le
premier ministre
où l autorité de l'état alors que l'état
d'urgence a été décrété
tous les jours il y à des attaques en
règle contre les forces de l'ordre les
policiers font face à des voyous armés
de barres de fer de harpon d'acide
d'engins incendiaires qui peuvent
blesser voire tuer ces femmes et ces
hommes défenseur de la république
stop à la haine anti-flic où l autorité
de l'état
quand face à des voyous on vous entend
donner des leçons avec des déclarations
magistral non suivies d'effet
techniquement l'état a la capacité à
donner des ordres pour mettre hors de
nuire ces voyous ou l autorité de l'état
quand chaque nuit on voit dans certaines
villes des regroupements ressemblant
plus à une cour des miracles plutôt qu'à
une agora républicaine les riverains
n'en peuvent plus les touristes du monde
entier sont atterrés et diffuse des
images désastreuses de notre pays où l
autorité de l'état
quand dans certains quartiers de notre
pays les règles d'une communauté se
substitue aux règles de la république
française où l autorité de l'état
quand même au sein de votre propre
gouvernement des ministres
s'affranchisse de la politique qu'il met
en oeuvre sous votre soi disantes
autorités vous incarnez l'inefficacité
politique
celle-ci rejaillit sur chacun d'entre
nous sur l'ensemble des élus votre voix
ne porte pas vous n'avez plus aucune
autorité
le verbe ne peut se substituer à
l'action alors monsieur le premier
ministre
ressaisissez-vous pour la dernière année
qui vous reste merci la parole et à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
monsieur le député
cochet où est la vérité dans votre
question dès lors que vous donnez des
leçons sur l'autorité de l'état alors
que vous avez soutenu pendant cinq ans
un gouvernement qui a supprimé 13 mille
postes dans la police et dans la
gendarmerie que vous avez soutenu avec
le même verbe haut et plein de nuances
un gouvernement qu a diminué de 17% les
crédits de fonctionnement de la police
et de la gendarmerie et qui était
tellement soucieux de l'autorité de
l'état qu'il aurait il réussi en cinq
ans a supprimé 13 unités de forces
mobiles dans les forces de sécurité dont
nous aurions bien besoin aujourd'hui
où est la vérité dans votre question
monsieur cochet lorsque vous laisser à
penser qu'il y aurait une espèce de
complaisance du gouvernement à l'égard
des casseurs alors que j'ai donné des
instructions extrêmement clair pour
qu'il soit interpellé et que depuis le
début du mouvement social en cours
il ya eu mille casseurs d'interpeller
que par une relation exceptionnelle
entre les forces de sécurité et les
procureurs de la république
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été mis en
comparution immédiate et que le droit
est systématiquement passer parce qu'il
n'y aura aucune complaisance du
gouvernement à l'égard de ceux qui s'en
prennent aux forces de l'ordre
masqué avec des cocktails molotov avec
des armes qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses et bien vis-à-vis de ces
casseurs nous sommes d'une fermeté
totale mais nous le sommes dans le
respect rigoureux des principes de
l'état de droit
parce que l'autorité de l'état c'est
aussi le respect à chaque instant des
principes de droit parce qu'ils sont
investis de la responsabilité politique
enfin ou et l'autorité de l'état chez
ceux qui préconisent qu'on interdise les
manifestations en contravention avec
tous les principes posés par le conseil
constitutionnel
l'autorité d'état c'est aussi le respect
de l'état de droit
c'est ce que nous faisons avec fermeté
et loin de la démagogie et du mensonge
quand aspirer votre question
merci